Shadid we want to hear now there's been
a brief statement relief released we are
understand or I understand from the the
now the Deputy Prime Minister Dominick
Robb the first Secretary of State in
actual fact in effect the Deputy Prime
Minister who is now deputizing for the
Prime Minister while he's in that
intensive care unit let's hear what the
foreign secretary is hard to say under
the medical care of the team it's in
Thomas's hospital after he was admitted
with persistent coronavirus symptoms
during the course of this afternoon the
Prime Minister's condition worsened and
on the advice of the medical team he was
moved in to a critical care unit so in
light of those circumstances the Prime
Minister asked me as first secretary to
deputize for him where necessary in
driving forward the government's plans
to defeat coronavirus and as you'll know
we he's been receiving excellent care as
in Thomas's Hospital and we'd like to
take this opportunity as a government to
thank NHS staff up and down the country
but all of their dedication hard work
and commitment in treating everyone
who's been affected by this awful virus
with the Prime Minister now in intensive
care this is obviously an extremely
serious situation I mean how how worried
should people be about his health and
about who's in charge of the government
well the government's business will
continue and the Prime Minister is in
safe hands with brilliant team at some
Thomas's Hospital and the focus of the
government will continue to be on making
sure that the Prime Minister's Direction
all the plans for making sure that we
can defeat coronavirus and pull the
country through this challenge will be
taken forward are you confident know
that the government is under control
tonight there's an incredibly strong
team spirit behind the prime minister
and making sure that we get all of the
plans that the Prime Minister's
instructed us to deliver to get them
implemented as soon as possible and
that's the way we'll bring the whole
country through the 'quran of
coronavirus challenge that we face right
now the man now now standing in for the